Speaker 1: Hey, this is sort of sort of exciting.
The David Pakman Show is now within striking
distance of 1.5 million YouTube subscribers.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky stars.
Every day you're not dead.
Speaker 1: Well, hold on a second,
because things are turning up. This is actually
a really great thing for us. There are very few
progressive YouTube channels like ours that are
at the 1.5 million subscriber level. In fact,
it's under four. We are extraordinarily close to
this milestone, and what we've started doing is
putting together a sort of calendar of interesting
things that will happen the sooner we achieve this
goal now. If we do nothing, nothing at all,
just like let subscribers climb naturally,
we are slated to hit 1.5 million on November
4th, so we would make it before Election Day,
which was originally my goal. But on a
recent stream, I floated the question well.
What might we be able to do to get people
interested in getting us there more quickly?
And people have started to contact me saying,
David, here's what I'm willing to do. If you
get to the goal by X state or by Y date. So
I think this is actually going to be really,
really fun. So if you have an idea of something
you would like to contribute, if we move the date
up, just email info David Pakman dot com. So
let me give you some examples. If we move the
date up from November 4th to October 21st and
by move it up, it just means people subscribe.
That's all it means. Just hit subscribe and it'll
happen sooner if we do it by October 21st. This is
unbelievable. Our viewer Kurt, has agreed to get
a panoramic back tattoo of Mount Rushmore with
five faces on it. This is the tattoo. Biden,
Obama, Clinton, FDR. And my face. Now, I don't
really know how I feel about someone getting
my face tattooed on them. It's a little weird,
to be perfectly frank, but it sounds interesting.
And Curt is willing to get that tattoo.
If we move the date up to October 21st. Okay. If
we move it all the way up to October 5th, which,
by the way, we're 5000 subscribers away, it's
completely plausible that we do that. We could
do that in two days if we if we really buckle
down, if we make it to 1.5 million by October
five. And from Utah suggested that I buy or rent
a unicycle and film myself writing it down the
street. That's fine. I will do that. I will buy
I will find a unicycle one way or another. If
we make it to 1.5 million by October five and
I will write it down the street, and then one
of our viewers espressos during our recent stream
said, David. If you make it to 1.5 million by Yom
Kippur, one of the Jewish High Holidays, which is
October 4th, I should do the Yom Kippur fast. Now,
as a non-religious Jew, I have never done the
fasted. I believe it's a sunset to sunset fast.
I'm willing to do it and I will live blog the
fasting and how how it is. Okay, so that's if we
make it by October 4th. Now the way I'm doing it
is because we don't want to just like have to pick
one of these things. If we make it to 1.5 million
by any of these dates, all of the things promised
from that date on should happen, right? So if we
do it on October 4th, I will do the Yom Kippur
fast and I will ride the unicycle and hopefully
Kurt will get the panoramic back tattoo. Okay. So
my request to you is two very simple things. One.
Subscribe to the YouTube channel. That's it. It's
free. It costs you nothing. Just subscribe to
the YouTube channel. And number two, if you're
willing to do something with our calendar here.
Oh, and we're seeing the numbers shift in real
time if you're willing to add something to the
calendar email info David Pakman dot com, let
me know what it is and we will get it on the
wackiness calendar. All right. Very, very good.